قبل ايام وجهت الحكومه المصريه وبشارات
رئاسيه بتفعيل ذلك القانون وتدوين اختيار
التبرع بالاعضاء بعد الوفاه في بطاقات
الهويه
[موسيقى]
اللي احنا هنعملها كمان في الرقم القومي
الرقم القومي المصري في خانه طول ارغب او
لارغب التبرع فيها فقط وكل واحد حر الارغم
محترم ونحترم جدا ولها ارغب بنحترم جدا
وده اراء شخصيه وبتطور مع الوقت من المهم
ان تكون هناك
مجتمعيه
باهميه التبرع بمشروعيه التبرع وبان
التبرع بعد الوفاء هو حفاظ على الحياه وان
الاديان همم الواحد من اهم همم ما جاءت
وناجت به هو الحفاظ على الحياه
وبالتالي التبرع هو جزء هام جدا من الحفاظ
على الحياه المتبرع له وان المتبرع بعد
الوفاه قد انتهت حياته همم يستطيع ان
يستكملها من خلال احياء اخرين